chose to get it babe we got a spark a
little ride let away I'm counting down
and do a starter and again we come to
play
yeah we play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday it is
our third day in our new home very
exciting really starting to feel the
warm and fuzzies here at a new toast HQ
really starting to feel at home here in
our new homes what I was gonna say but
it was a home twice that same sentence
all we do know but I'm also feeling the
warm and fuzzies because I would feel
remiss if I wasn't being remiss I'm just
happy to be alive like I sat on the show
yesterday I mean like I'm gonna be a
piece of garbage tomorrow morning and I
just want to give myself a big pat on
the back for going I don't know
weeknight drinking having fun but not
taking it to the point where I can't
function the next day yeah this is this
is how you like slowly start to become a
functioning alcoholic it is exciting
yeah where the word adulting comes into
play I had no I [ __ ] hate that word I
hate that word too but like it's
necessary like I went to watch happens
live last night which by the way I
haven't been in so long and you think
like I've been actually many times and I
Bart ended and you think like it loses
its like glamour but it's such an
exciting place to be one not only like
live television lalala but it's like
Bravo was just so and even Ben was like
getting like the he and he like had no
idea what was going on what a production
they put on yes show biz it's a very
exciting thing it's a very exciting
means we do it every day here at the
morning toast but you know it's nice not
to be jaded um I just need to document
my night really quickly um benchmarks by
the wonderful amazing toasters that I
met everywhere I went last night ready
mm-hmm
me embedding a dinner we the Boston's
I've office is like so far downtown
Tribeca so we needed somewhere to go and
you know where we when there's an
American cut on Greenwich Street and it
was chic you would love like this is I
know food looks really good I thought
you were at Polo bar I never leave my
house so I never can give good
restaurant recommendations but if
anyone's coming to New York I've been to
two stellar restaurants American cut is
an uptown steakhouse that's like fancy
but I guess there's one downtown very
chic and there was a bartender there
named Jessa who was such a big toaster
like she was so cool
she brought I knew she was a toaster cuz
I ordered I coke and she brought it over
and it was the biggest guy conk I've
ever seen
I know you need a big one I just I love
you so much and then she brought over
like this caviar thing she was just so
nice some mushrooms she was I can I can
eat any of this it's for Ben she just
really was like it's really like
elevated the night and she was making
great margarita it's like it was just a
good time then they went watch happen
five and met a girl who personally met a
million toasters were in the audience
but I met a girl who works I watched
Robins live was a toaster her name is
Belle what kind of job does she have
there an important one because she's in
charge of the music that plays before
the show and she [ __ ] play toast
that's great so I was just like living
but she's not like the Booker of guests
who are podcasting no she was like you
she bartend like though make it happen
you know yeah and also just a little
side note that I think people would find
it really interesting is when they
introduce the guests before the show
starts they like bring them out to get
all the the crowd hyped up they play on
display by melissa gorga
which is such a good song to play it's
great I was like why maybe the song and
I just thought it was such a great attic
job then I met another toaster wearing
her toast merch sitting in the Oprah
seats at watch Robins why was she in the
Oprah seats I don't know why she was
special she was just I've been to watch
happens live many times and I've never
sat in Oprah seats and everyone who said
Sarah's like somehow connected to Andy
or like if it was like Mamaw
you know yeah yeah it's so it's a
prestigious thing and she was wearing
the Rolling Stone charcoal cross on your
I'm sorry t-shirt and she was there
representing her toast family in the
Oprah seats I watched nothing love to
see it so those are the I hope she got
on TV those are some of the amazing
toasters just a few of the amazing
toasters I met on my wild night out and
in my safe love to hear about toasty
encounters truly toasty encounters um
we're so glad you guys are watching live
today we want to just give a few quick
updates on our studio situation because
for those of you watching on YouTube
podcasters this doesn't apply to you
because the audio is more premium than
ever but on YouTube there's like a
hissing white noise sound that we are
working to get rid of we are aware of
the issue by tomorrow it will be gone
but thank you for your patience and if
it really about theirs you just listen
as a podcast because it's not on the
podcast
honestly I listened to it yesterday
because people were like and it elicits
and honestly it was nothing of the deal
so something we also have our carpet
coming today which I'm really excited
about it's very plenty carpet and our
couch should be arriving sometime in the
next week or two just lots of updates we
are getting a brighter film for the
window but we are just we are here
constantly evolving and for the record
is not a green screen or these are real
windows but just when I see
oh yeah a helicopter is going by
sometimes birds fly by there's smoke off
the chimneys over there when my close-up
camera is on you can see the streets and
the cars by the way so now we have three
cameras gets hello rich hi um we have
our individual yeah oh no that's mine hi
oh man Instagram but when you look at my
window we have a north east of you so um
please hit me up with my solo camera
because maybe north east of you and I
get Long Island City and there's nothing
wrong with Long Island City and then and
then a jockeys camera and how are you I
get Upper East Side's yes so it's just
like not fair and honestly I think we
should rotate no but you that your chair
is the better seat because we both have
the same side that we like and I let you
have the chair also ever since I have
this thing on my face like I just cannot
sit on that side right so like you have
the better chair you have the better
side in general and it's your side for
everything and now finally like the
underdog has her comeuppance moment oh
you have like such a chic New York City
of you like honestly you look at me and
it's like I'm doing a show in you know
Idaho no but like Long Island City's
really up-and-coming Amazon almost moves
there almost it wasn't good enough Long
Island City is really up-and-coming like
I actually want to move there you get so
much space and so much value when we
were actually looking for studio space
we looked a lot in Long Island City and
I was so tempting we were gonna move
into some of these buildings like they
had pools yoga studios they had that
helmet on studio and one of the huge
apartment buildings like it was
sickening to just go do tours of like
one two bedroom apartments that
literally cost a fraction and they have
a pool rooftop deck it's all party rooms
movie theater rooms and I don't leave my
apartment ever so like it doesn't matter
what location I'm in and I'm telling you
like Long Island City is where it's at
and like I think I could see myself
there could you I could see myself being
the queen of Queens
whether you're patent leather pants and
our squeaky chairs are not a good time
but you can't I know but this show like
needed some pain can I just saw like I
should be the one to bring it today
until our pink accents arrived our pink
rug comes to am very excited about it
it's a Jill Zarin rug I just have to say
Jill Zarin makes a fine rug I have one
of them in my house to me ma'am very
premium is there anything else you want
to chat about housekeeping items
it no I hope we're recording a great
page right up so do you are with Olivia
spoiler alert spoiler alert so if you're
not a peach remember head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast we're
doing you know a one-on-one interview
exclusive with the first pregnancy and
the first pregnant SPS it's really so
exciting so we'll be taking questions
from the patrons later today oh we do
have an announcement that we want to
share housekeeping yeah 2020 is is
roaring in and we want to give you the
date for ticket sales so that everyone
can set their alarms and whatnot we took
your advice we asked if you guys wanted
tickets to go on sale during the
holidays so you could get it for someone
as a gift for yourself as a gift and you
guys said no holiday no expensive enough
let us have get some breathing time so
we are now gonna give you about two
weeks notice yes
so tickets will go on sale for patreon
members on Tuesday January 21st so if
you want to make sure that you 100% have
a ticket to camp toast and if you're
like buying for your friends and you
just like don't want that anxiety become
a patreon member and you can buy your
ticket early and then they will go on
sale for everyone else on Wednesday
January 22nd so patreon has a whole day
exclusive to get tickets I'm a lot of
the questions I get asked are like it's
impossible for tickets to sell out in
patron and it's definitely possible it's
possible it did not happen last year a
majority of the tickets were sold but we
don't know anything could happen and
especially after last year's camp toast
which was like so incredible so moving
like iconic inspiring vomit-inducing
incredible incredible amazing I don't
know what the demands gonna be so it up
give birth to it put it in a blender mix
it up yeah exactly so if you are
stressing about it become a patreon
member if you're buying for a big group
of people and like your extra stressed
patreon and you and I need to put some
time on our calendar it's like to really
make some decisions about cam shows
because like we are elevating activities
we are elevating yeah moments elevating
events and we just have to take you to
the next level where we went from cam
toes want to camp toes to was such a
leap that I don't even know how we can
make camp toast 3 I mean have a lot of
ideas but how we could do it even bigger
I know but it was mostly elite because
of the weather and that's just out of
our hands yeah and the amount of people
I think we're gonna have the same amount
of people right as last year yes I think
it was a good amount we still got
meet everyone we're gonna make some
changes we heard you know comments about
last year people really were upset that
they spent the whole weekend with us but
didn't get a picture with us which is so
crazy I feel like I see them now at mean
grades I'm like I know you but like we
don't have a picture together so we have
taken everything into consideration I
just can't believe we're going into our
third camp toast like this little idea
it's really my favorite way to spend
Memorial Day weekend I couldn't agree
more and I want in by even more friends
of ours this year because it's just such
a fun friendly weekend and having we
brought Kristen DeMarco having them
there like made it so much more fun
because technically like it's work for
us like it's so weird like what do you
do this weekend I'm working technically
but it's so much fun and we love camp so
much in the guide so many in our friend
love can so my friends of the toast I
agreed that we should be bringing more
camp friends okay cool and Theo is gonna
be coming back he had the time of his
life I'm really so excited last year I
was I'm sure I got anxious leading up to
it because it's like a lot of
responsibility leave Undertaker but this
year I'm even more excited than I was
last year because um it was just so much
fun it was so much fun I just like
commit to get my bunk all set up I think
my favorite part about camp I mean
there's so many but I love that we go up
a day before we get to like spend a day
at camp like all alone I can't huh we go
to like Target we got our bedding like
that's so fun we go to it because this
is the camp that we actually went to
summer camp at so we like know all the
restaurants barley Creek like I just
that's my favorite part of the camp
totally I'm really so excited I'm really
excited for spring weirdly I'm not it's
like a weather person or a seasons
person like I don't clearly with your
pink pants in your shirt I was actually
thinking this is such a spring breeze
and a short sleeve shirt okay but I'm
wearing boots and I'm wearing my cleany
puffer no you're and I'm wearing pants
which is like better than tights but I
just the days are so short in the winter
it's crazy it gets dark before five
o'clock right now it's like walking home
gotta be it's you know it's tough out
there for a woman walking home alone at
night you just try to leave work at five
o'clock and it's dark already get your
pepper spray for sure we need a pepper
spray sponsor do or like a mace or like
a Swiss Army knife love it love that
protect yourselves you know where you
think is a sin purse yeah you know you
can't get like pepper spray or mace in
New York of course I know a lot of girls
who drive to New Jersey because only the
crazies are allowed to have weapons so
true I heard the craziest story in the
New York's teens group what um cuz like
it was it was a story there was just
seven ticket of how fucked-up knee or
cos this girl was like
I just moved here from Texas the
craziest thing happened to me today I
was having lunch it was super nice out
in Bryant Park I'm eating like a salad
with beans in it and you know they have
those like public tables with our chairs
so she was sitting alone in someone sat
in the other chair and was like what
kind of beans are in your salad and she
was like kidney beans or whatever and
the person put their hand in her salad
I'm a that oh my god this city you guys
it's going to [ __ ] it's so crazy did you
see that really sweet story about the
swastikas on the subway I did okay it's
such a sweet story like everyone getting
together the hand sanitizer to wipe them
off slavery is that like everyone was on
a train car and like the advertisements
had already been ID swastikas all over
them Jews go back in the oven and
everyone was just like on the train
looking at each other while like this
Nazi paraphernalia was just like
casually written on the wall and then
someone had the idea to wipe it off with
hand sanitizer and they all and the
whole train came together to get it all
off and like they really put their
tissues together it was really good
really sweet but like what about the
fact that there's a Nazi running around
it's sweet but like right like by the
anti-semitism it's just out of control
in this city like we're joking about it
but like what the [ __ ] no because you
have to joke about things that make you
so [ __ ] terrified yeah and I keep
saying I actually like having oh by the
way and you know what I've never spoken
about on the show but I always forget
about because I was talking to someone
who wasn't Jewish and I told him the
story and they were like freaking out
and I guess it's like such a big deal
because this story about the swastika is
on the train like went viral
do you know that Ben and his family had
to leave their childhood home that they
like lived in on the Upper East Side
like for ten years because someone put a
swastika on their door no I don't think
I knew that it's a crazy story and on
their mailbox and they like it was like
a condo and they took it to the board
I'm like literally nobody cared so they
had to leave oh my god nuts that's crazy
it crimes hate to see it he to see it
okay well I hate to have a pit so early
in the morning so let's just pivot I
already have a pit because I'm
absolutely starving like it's a physical
pit Oh true starvation ation cuz I got
home last night and I didn't have any
snacks because I'm turning into a
responsible adult really do you want to
tell us more about it no honestly oh
okay well without further ado I guess
it's time feels like time who knows sure
time is of the essence
it's
yes it is I'm trying to sing to cover up
the cider in behind us so you don't
think you're getting run over by their
cups you guys it's it's just a siren
outside if you're listening to the
podcast while driving to work you don't
have you mirror because you're not
getting close over you can continue to
not wear a seatbelt or go over the speed
limit
I think the siren is gone oh wait it's
not it's still churning okay I'm not
kidding I don't even know if they can
hear the siren anyways without further
ado eight it's time for the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast a lot like police yeah
like they called than all the big guns
all the big guns
um Thank You Jackie for letting us know
that it is time and it is definitely
time but you know me I got something to
say and what I have to say is that
today's episode is brought to you by
daily harvest let's face it New Year's
resolutions don't always stick
especially the ones that focus on health
because those require the most work like
I did say I was gonna stop eating bread
baskets this year but last night I had
the most delicious basket um it was like
a biscuit almost I want to say but daily
Harve it makes it so easy to eat well
they deliver thoughtfully source chef's
crafted food right to your door
everything can be prepared in five
minutes or less daily the harvest is
something that you can enjoy year-round
as something's going on something's
going on oh my god our building on fire
I don't know
jelly harvest is something that you can
enjoy year-round as a quick solution to
get the fruits and vegetables you need
everyday daily harvest works directly
with farmers to harvest organic fruits
and vegetables at their peak and freezes
them with 24 hours to lock in their
nutrients everything stays fresh until
you're ready to enjoy it choose for more
than 65 options like smoothies hearty
soups harvest balls and overnight oats
whether you're at home at your desk or
on the go daily harvest is the easiest
way to have a delicious and nutritious
meal or snack go to daily harvest comm
enter the promo code toast to get $25
off your first box that's promo code
toast tio ast for $25 off your first box
at daily harvest comm again that's daily
harvest dot-com check it out promo code
toast he chews for more than 65
different options
I love a harvest ball I really do sign
on eat good American camper loves her
daily harvest because when she doesn't
have a time to make breakfast in the
morning because when her deadbeat mother
and now you met American cambers grandma
right that's why she lives with her
grandma because her mom is deadbeat
Darrin out drinking every night at the
local pub she relies so much on the cows
are seeking guidance shed like a
parental figure she's seeking counseling
but that's why she also is with her
grandma Gracie
also I just want to say about the sirens
like that's what you get for being in
New York City and that's why I'm moving
to Long Island City
oh so fabulous like I think Leigh and my
better like watch TV and there's never
not a sound that I can hear it's so
crazy I'll watch other people's like
vlogs in New York I was even watching
the Kiara frog me documentary and she's
like at one point in a hotel in New York
City and it's sirens the entire time
know also then when I go elsewhere like
if I'm in the Hamptons I wake up so
early the silence is it's [ __ ] scary
like yeah I can I know I love the silent
I can sleep through like people talking
it's crazy in my old apartment I lived
on a super high floor like a sixteenth
floor and I could wake up from hearing
people on the street just chatting Wow
that's how like New York is just such a
it's like Carrie Bradshaw even though
she's the what she did say like if New
York had a sound it would be the siren
you are kind of free to it'd be an apple
also I know you tell me yesterday that
you recorded I'm the new a show pop in
the morning I did you watch it I watched
the first three minutes of the premiere
episode just to see what it looked like
um not enough to say if it was good or
bad they were the bartenders last night
our competition like I wish that they
had just like taken some time to explain
who they were
yeah um and like why we should care and
get invested yeah but we'll see they're
very good looking in person I was like
shucks like that's why they you know I'm
no talented am I come in who who hosts
the new enews in the like the 7:00 a.m.
they jus - because they were on one side
last night saying they have to be up
they be show at 7:00 that's so crazy
they wake up at 3:00 a.m. to do that no
I know and then they do 7:00 to 8:00 and
then they have to wait til 11:00 and
then they do like their fun show yeah
seems like a lot of work seems like you
guys need someone to carry the load
Hey booyah we don't wake up and
I will take the three o'clock shift I
just everyday I wake up and say when we
started the toast
why didn't we - 11:30 like even though
show is like a very reason blabber I get
very good sleep and I don't even know if
we pushed our show back one hour would I
feel any different you wouldn't because
then you would just get used to it I
wish it was 12:30 and then you would
have less time in the day because the
day would start for you later I actually
think the time of our show is absolutely
perfect
I agreed like and you really can like go
out and have a few drinks and if you're
in bed I was in bed by 1:00 mm-hmm and I
got a decent 8 hours yeah and for people
who work like you can get a little bit
of work done watch the show and then
it's lunch that's the best point hey
Sally what's good the best part
especially would be the guest like you
you are done and it's officially
lunchtime yeah
we just saying love love lunch for you
guys okay and for me are you ready for
the story I am because I feel like there
is a lot going on that I need to discuss
and also we're gonna recap Vanderpump
rules because I didn't watch it this
morning and I have a lot of thoughts
that I feel like may not be popular okay
um I watched it but I take an Advil PM
so I hope I remember my thoughts I have
the craziest dreams on Advil PM I
literally remember sleep talking to
Bennett for a full hour telling in how I
thought Theo was a reincarnated ghost of
our Father well he is so that's not so
crazy though it was a true awakening
because I had never thought about that
before but then after having that
conversation with Ben I fully actually
believe that Theo is a reincarnated
spirit of our Father fully believe like
he's such a support animal like I can't
even talk about I'll start crying like
okay so true let's get into our first
story like a bit of crazy legal news
this morning Jennifer actually we have
two bits of crazy legal news I'm gonna
have to unchain blac chyna for it
because it's really crazy you know what
I could live with that I actually kind
of miss her she's so crazy okay Jennifer
Lopez's production company has been sued
for forty million dollars by the
stripper who inspired hustlers that's so
weird because last night at drinks with
Jackson Britney like we were just
talking about like things we have in
common we're talking about hustlers and
I was explaining to them that she's
suing them 40 million dollars why cuz
she just thinks they didn't tell an
accurate story well so it's clear that
it's about her because based on this
article um yeah the like hustlers of
scores yeah um and but they changed I
mean but then they also put in things
that she says didn't happen like herb
cooking drugs in the kitchen where she
lives with her daughter right and like
it's defamatory she's claiming it is and
so here's here's the juice so dude but
did JLo
claim that this did they publicly say
that it's about this woman
no but they publicly said it's about
this article and the article you
disaster woman real name and everything
according to court documents obtained by
the blast the 50 year old production
company Nero Qian productions STX
Entertainment Gloria Sanchez productions
and pull sisters LLC is being sued for
40 million dollars by the woman who
inspired the actresses character Ramona
in the film her name is Samantha Barr
bash why do they name her Ramona I don't
know because there's a New York City
hustler the publication further reports
that barbash quote claims the film
producers approached her before
production to obtain a consent waiver
from her for the production of the film
and their ultimate betrayal of her she
refused to sign off on the consent or
waive her privacy rights the film is
based on a 2015 New York magazine
article titled the hustlers at scores
which details the real-life events of
barb ash and her time as a stripper at
scores gentlemen club in New York
ultimately barbash claims that Lopez's
production company used her likeness and
her story without her permission
defaming her in the process according to
TMZ more specifically TMZ reports that
according to the suit barb ash said her
character and hustlers was portrayed as
quote using and manufacturing illegal
substances in her home where she lived
with her child according to the
publication barb ash added that those
claims and portrayals of her likeness
were untrue and offensive interests and
I mean she she's suing for 20 million
dollars in competent compensatory
damages and 20 million dollars in
punitive damage and she also wants an
order requiring producers to turn over
all copies of the movie ok well that's
silly
she does have like a little bit of a
thin argument when it comes to like the
consent and name and likeness that of
her whatever in the defamatory she
actually might win a little bit about it
she's obviously being insane asking that
every movie be taken off the market
mm-hmm but I kind of feel her I mean at
the end of the day it's like it's so
silly at this point like what you like
the crux of the movie like your criminal
like you know like right you drugged and
robbed men right it's like we weren't
judging you for making the drugs in your
apartment no right like that's like the
least of our concerns and honestly like
I just feel like the more the longer
this woman stays out of
the better uh yeah look I don't know
about from a legal standpoint because
they did change her name and I'm sure
that they said somewhere like these are
based on we're not totally true um but
from like a human standpoint seems like
she has a case you know one thousand
percent just one like a totally
third-party perspective because it's
like clear that based on this article
like if you just do the smallest bit of
research you can figure out who it's
about one thousand percent and maybe
like she didn't give them permission to
use her likeness which is why maybe they
changed her name
yeah but is that enough no and when I've
been seeing any press that they've done
about hustlers they talk about how
commendable it was that they did the
movie so fast I think they said they
filmed it in 29 days which is like a
crazy thing in Hollywood um so what kind
of seems like maybe they cut some
corners cuz they wanted to get it out
maybe but I don't think they would cut
legal corners I don't know well see it
yeah this seems really crazy it does and
not totally far-fetched dude in jail is
gonna win the Oscar no me neither
no I don't but I don't think she was
great yeah Oscar nominations haven't
come out yet have that oh no that is do
you think she's even gonna get nominated
I do um I hope so because I want to see
her there each other and I loved them
and I think hustlers what that nominated
so she'll be there regardless so you
think Lilly Reinhardt will be at the
Oscars ooh
she should be yeah to be where you kept
that movie hustlers ya know it's like I
saw it a long time ago um I just have a
few thoughts about it since it's like
Oscar buzz worthy um me and Ben watched
it and we both really liked it but we
both have the same came to the same
consensus was that it was almost almost
ruined by um the main character oh not
Jayla what's her name Constance whoo
Constance whoo
um she was horrible like sure her
character was horrible her acting was
horrible like she was horrible really I
didn't oh my god she bothered me so much
Oh ever since now I know what I know
about her basin on the press saying that
she's a monster diva she isn't a write
to me because she's not that talented
interesting is innocent but but keke
palmer can save any film oh I'm sorry
and then it really really cemented for
me that keke palmer is one of the best
actresses of our generation and I stand
so hard and I've been a lifelong Stan
from True Jackson all the way to
hustlers like I I so like support her
and like every endeavor she wants to be
a host she's hosting out Keke Palmer
Strahan whatever it's called Kiki Sarah
and Michael and whatever
Mikey Sarah him it's so good like I just
support her she's so beautiful like
I loved her and she was spectacular in
that movie and they actually think if
she had gotten Constance Wu Constance
was role it would have been a better
movie she is so she's a dynamic actress
she's so dynamic it's not just funny
life sorry to this man I don't know this
man and I've seen this man if this man
walking in the street she is everything
and she's also like an influencer like
she's just I love her and that would be
really and I'd you know what should I
have another thought about doing
meanwhile I love Lily Reinhardt um I
didn't think it was the right role for
her she really is not believable as a
stripper like at all she's she's almost
plagued by the fact that she's such a
good actress on Riverdale because it
makes it impossible to see her as
anything okay but what if you're not
someone who watches Riverdale she just
to me like she did not give me the vibe
of a girl who would like ever find
herself in that situation hmm she liked
her face looks like she has a moral
compass and more girls with moral
compasses just don't drug random men who
work on Wall Street they just don't they
just don't okay well are you ready for
our next story a bit of happy vacation
news Adele has been spotted looking
happy and fit during her island getaway
with Harry Styles and James Corden this
is like a very controversial topic
because a lot of people pictures of them
resurface of them on the beach she looks
completely different yeah well I
actually wasn't even gonna talk about
her different look I'm just excited that
she's vacationing with Harry Styles and
James Corden it's so much fun yeah um
where was it in Quiller Antigua in the
Caribbean I think it was one of one of
the Anguilla yeah I go in the the a
Caribbean islands confused yeah um but
there was a lot of chatter about this in
our Facebook group and lot of people who
like tell looks amazing Adele looks
amazing and the picture that they put up
a cheque she didn't look good she just
looked like she had lost a ton of weight
and it's like just making it synonymous
the fact that she lost weight you look
amazing if you're skinny right when it's
like actually was a terrible picture of
her um but she looks so different like
her face her like everything looks
different yeah in that one picture but
like look at her running on the beach
here she's happy she's such a good time
like she acts like such a fun-loving gal
she really does and as long as she's
happy I'm happy for her you know that is
the Adele on the beach is like the by
2020 like mentality you're 2020 by like
during Emily with Harry Styles and James
Corden like what a crew I just feel like
those
my people yeah like that's like the
British elites yeah like they're like
that like back in the day like they're
the British aristocrats like the
noblemen you know we're just a sorry
people she would think like Harry Styles
and Adele at all like might have
something going on absolutely not I
think that they actually might do a song
together even though tell it doesn't
collab know if you could see a gel
collab with anyone like honestly like
Josh Groban like not know like no sir I
don't I feel like should we just go in a
totally different direction
like yeah yeah yeah plus one because we
don't need like more Adele on an Adele
song I love when celebrities hang out
together I love when they go on vacation
together like what do you think the
housing situation was you know like to
think either house was it a hotel I
think they all probably had their own
house and then they there was like a
pool that they met up at like with a bar
you think
uh-huh and like who else was there
obviously let's make three celebrities
but I'm sure like everyone had like
friends yeah and they're yeah they're
home friends they're school friends
their camp random let's see that might
be how they're connected like they both
are friends was like one person yeah
like one person ended I went to camp
with went to school at Harry's yes yeah
and then James Corden was there are a
they're freshman year of course
someone's got all these kids in line
he's the counselor he's the British
counts announcer Corden counts are
coordinate Meyerbeer camber James Corden
is like friends with so many celebrities
and everyone seems like really really
like him it's it's kind of how like it
reminds me of how everyone that goes on
Ellen's show and like it's like fake
friends with Alan but then people
actually really low-key hang out with
James Corden he gets invited to a lot of
stuff I think hang out with Ellen she
went to like the Cowboys game with
Corrie gamble remember that was good
true that's true Corrie gamble just
loves popping up another crew I could
maybe see myself with yeah George Bush I
think that people I think James Corden
is probably like such a cool nice guy
like I think people really really like
dig him totally and Kanye was like so
taken by him and when he mary playing
karaoke hate him ya know I just win and
if you can impress like Adele Kanye
Harry Styles I think you're at a good
hashtag winning
member knows a thing Charlie Sheen
Charlie Sheen the Denise Richards up at
all I know okay you ready for our next
Ram and they excited to get your take I
am but before before you get my take I
need to I need to own the now is that
okay mmm-hmm would you let me you should
be embarrassed if I owned the now no
never there's mall business owner so
important that's what I'm so important
to you on the now
that's literally there's so many people
listening so many people watching and
they too must own the now Jacky
literally taking the words respect that
if there's no engineer for small
business owners or people who produce
their own podcast like us being plugged
in and prepared when an opportunity
comes up is crucial those moments happen
all the time they're happening right now
and having a business card that shows
how professional you are in your pocket
ready to hand out is the first step to
making something happen I mean we now
have our own office like we must be
carrying around and you know what last
night I met someone and he and I said do
you have a card and he did and it was
literally like perfect he was owning the
now yeah and it's like you just need a
card yeah we did you did cuz in that
moment the now was owned do you know
what I'm saying it's it's hard for
people to understand if they haven't
owned the now but that's why it's so
important because your next big
opportunity is coming right now we're
here to help you own the now with free
shipping on any business card in any
quantity choose whatever style finished
shape or paper you like and get free
shipping and because you can pick the
colors fonts designs and images it means
you can create something as unique and
compelling as your own business if
you're ready to get started today plug
in your information get your logo into
hundreds of fresh designs tailored to
your type of company or you can upload
your own original layout if you're
feeling brave and creative pick the
paper stock the style the quantity
that's right for you you can even
upgrade to a unique touch like rounded
corners order and receive your cards
with free economy shipping as if you
needed any more reason to choose
vistaprint you can feel good knowing
that they use only carefully sort
selected inks and responsibly sourced
paper stocks your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or your money back
they will make it right misprint wants
you to be able to own the now in any
situation which is why our listeners
will get free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity just go to
vistaprint.com enter the promo code
toast for free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity it's a
limited time offer so make sure to own
the now right now at Mista print.com
promo code toast it's like the sirens
know when I'm doing an ad and they just
start signing but I don't think that
well about one was hurt I was thinking
the same thing sorry to our sponsors
I don't know these sponsors okay are you
ready now for our story that I need to
get your opinion on yeah YouTube star
Emma Chamberlain covers Cosmopolitan's
February 2020 issue influencer Emma
Chamberlain and
ten year-old who's vlogging style has
turned into a lifestyle brand that
includes her own cold brew coffee packs
which I want to talk to you about a
partnership with Louboutin and a hosting
cameo on Dick Clark's New Year's rockin
Eve with Ryan Seacrest 2020 it's now a
Cosmo magazine cover star the team
covers the February issue of the mag and
opens up about how social media shaped
for self esteem and why she doesn't want
to be labeled and influenced her despite
boasting more than 8.5 million YouTube
subscribers so here are some pull quotes
from the article just sharing you know
what's on Emma's mind quote I think the
word the word influencer is kind of
disgusting let's use me as an example if
someone is calling me an influencer
they're saying that my job is to
influence and I don't think that's true
I prefer to entertain and be a friend I
don't want to influence she calls the
pressures to look perfect in LA a quote
bloodbath Chamberlain also said that she
refuses to endorse weight loss teas or
shakes like some of her contemporaries
I'm also because she doesn't need you
it's not like right I don't think those
companies paid that well and she's
working with Louboutin yeah it's not
even an option that's but don't make it
seem like you're taking a moral high
ground like 100 percent it's not even an
option maybe right now like maybe in a
few years on the downward spiral but
absolutely no it's not like you were
eliminated night one on The Bachelor
like right you have a good time you have
options she says like your your grind is
your grind and I'm not going to get in
the way of that I just think that
growing up on social media gave me
eating issues as a kid I literally have
struggled with that my whole life almost
every person I've met has had some form
of an eating disorder I mean I've had I
don't want to trigger anyone but so many
she's also vowed never to use any photo
manipulation software to change the way
she looks okay I just want to say like
her being on the cover is everything
like I think this is such a good move by
Cosmo like finally a magazine being in
tune with what's necessary like she is
the voice of a generation not my
generation but I like her videos margot
loves her she's so cute she's really
smart like I think that her being on the
cover is such a great idea for everyone
I think it's mutually beneficial for her
for them and I think she looks amazing
and stunning and she's actually very
well-spoken she's like a smart girl
mm-hmm
I just think this is a 10 out of 10 all
around I think everyone whoever who's
ever idea this was like great job
yeah you know I love to like tear Cosmo
down I do but I'm so here for this
magazine who like claims to support
women when everything they write is so
[ __ ] negative yeah they're Jezebel no
the
they write it's like a parody of the
female voice and it's a parody of like
journalism like the amount of research
is trash 100 and I love them people like
celebrities and Cosmo articles and like
by the way this isn't true it's always
Cosmo it's always untrue I hope that may
local nail salon gets this issue of
Cosmo said I get to read this um and I
think she's such a cutie and I really
like that her first venture as an
entrepreneur and I won't say influence
their entertainer um is a coffee company
like a novel like a month ago mm-hmm I
had no idea what she was like she kept
teasing I think this is genius
genius I was asking Snitch about its
Mitch Chamberlain came over by the way
to me like snitch is Emma Chamberlain
very simple it looks so similar like
they they act similar with the coffee
like um and yeah so Margo is just my
resident she's Arlen House yeah yeah
she's my will Chamberlain yeah and what
did she think I asked her if she would
get the coffee she said um it's like
kind of like your own cold brew kit it's
like a tea bag of coffee yeah they'd you
have to do it overnight in your fridge
um and it just didn't seem like it
worked with Margo's lifestyle yeah but
she seemed like excited about it you
know it definitely is for a certain type
of coffee drinker and a certain type of
girl who it's honestly like the Bisco
girl aesthetic that like Emma
Chamberlain literally started yeah or
like a college student who doesn't have
a Keurig in their dorm but it's a
mini-fridge and they want like a big tub
of coffee for the for the week yeah it's
really smart and you know what like I
like people who do different things like
do I need this coffee know will I buy it
no but I just like sorry entertainers
who do different things like don't come
out with just a clothing line or a line
of sunglasses like everyone else like
this is actually cool it's very on bread
for her because if you watch our videos
her whole day is revolved around her
coffee with her almond milk latte like I
think it's really interesting and it's
something no one's done before and like
if it's successful she's literally no
competition like you know it's our
coffee sorry entertainer coffee also um
starting like a consumer product like
this is the easiest like the best way to
become like super successful like Kylie
yeah you know yep honest company janae
Galba I feel as though she I don't know
who's like on her team and who manages
her and where she like gets her advice
from I feel like a lot of it is from
Derek Blasberg it is um but she's very
well managed she's well managed honestly
I did
think for a while like when she shot to
fame and like then she was going at
Paris Fashion Weekend partnering with
Louie Vuitton like it was a little silly
obviously like you're Emma Chamberlain
Louis Vuitton won't strike with you like
you're never gonna turn that down well
I'm like a branding perspective it
actually makes no goddamn sounds like if
you watch our videos
she's obviously changed a lot since
moving to LA but her whole thing was
like she just doesn't give a [ __ ] like
about clothes like she was just like
messy bun like never had her nails done
so like obviously she's changed a lot
since like becoming famous and moving to
LA for not Nevada or good might just
like changed um and the Louboutin
partnership like did it make the most
sense to me but to me like for what I
think Louie Vuitton wants to be it
actually makes perfect sense like
they're really Vuitton yeah but also for
her because they're a such like an
elevated luxury brand but a lot of this
stuff that they're putting out now is
like more street style and like you know
boots and just purses that like our
crossbody like the one that you had
right and I could see Emma Chamberlain
wearing that and the girls that they
work with like sophie Turner is that
cool girl and there's just being the
brand for the everyday cool girl and who
has a lot of money yeah we're just once
one nice purse yeah I think I agreed
that the partnership is great for Tom
yeah
and it's obviously amazing for Emma
Chamberlain like no one would ever turn
that down when you just think about it
from a branding perspective it's like
who's she like create like the image
that she created for herself online like
being the face of Louboutin like makes
no goddamn sense but people change
people about they know she does she she
was on YouTube she's being one kind of
girl they she makes a lot of money and
she wants a designer person Louie
Vuitton is the purse she's gonna buy by
the way and I love that for her because
I am a Louboutin collector I know Jackie
sent me the most amazing movie talking
duffel bag on the reel reel and I just I
couldn't pull the trigger it was so much
money but like I started to collect like
that's my brand of choice I am literally
a drug pusher when it comes to getting
Claudia to buy hands who's actually
going to screenshot what your text sent
and put it on my Instagram straight but
then I thought people be like you're so
out of touch because Jackie sent me a
duffel bag that was $3,000 which I
obviously did not I didn't intend for
you to actually get it but it was
sickening yeah and so I I said oh my god
and Jackie said I think you need it and
I said but it's three K she goes you
can't put a price on happiness okay I
mean that's a true statement though what
is it that you're a drug pusher you are
Tina Fey Jewish people I push I push
people I specifically push you because
we're the opposite when it
to buying like luxury items like I'm so
frivolous I'm out of control and
sometimes if I push out into someone
else it might stop me from buying
something you know you push people yeah
but I think you need to be pushed you're
a butcher
yeah no I'm AB control Tita buddy but
that's part of library that's hard my
resolution like I really haven't shopped
in 2020 really yes that's great you
haven't you have a big problem what a
huge you know what family talks about it
no you have like such a big problem like
every day showing up with a new [ __ ]
designer daddy back but like it makes me
so happy and you can't put a price on
happiness no but you can because it's
out of control and like I think you have
a business how could you even say that
everyone in the family talks about it
like you are so out of control
Wow hurtful no true you need to know you
need to face your demons
you are literally Rebecca Bloomwood okay
things like we're literally having
brunch and we're also exhausted me only
me like if any of these [ __ ] want to
go shopping like we're not coming I'm
like yes let me be the deal we sit down
I could shop like yeah we know you could
[ __ ] sit down you need to freeze your
credit cards okay and I'm fine you guys
I'm fine it's gonna be fine
and you know what right now I'm a really
good place every time I come to your
part but like the boxes and like you
come to my house it's like Amazon boxes
like I ordered a stapler you know Jackie
has like [ __ ] Efendi the real be like
insane okay well you know what like it's
their collectors items and their
Testament it's notes in invest don't
throwing money down the drain I totally
agree but you're just at a level where
it's like out of control but like if I
was collecting coins would you look down
on me how much do the coins cost I don't
know but like people collect things it's
a hobby yeah but people don't collect
like you just are out and they'll say
something else yes like I enjoy to buy
purses but I really wear all of them I
wear everything that I buy I wear to the
to the ground you wear it a ton totally
so I'm getting my um my money's worth
out of control and then I'll resell it
and I'll make money because it's an
investment okay next
ESMA next up Rob Kardashian wants
primary custody of daughter dream claims
blac chyna is a risk
on this is our basket of people with
China China means we don't talk about
them anymore because it's just too much
it started when like China was in the
news every single day like about her
bagina being posted on Instagram before
noon and it just got to be too much
trust me he said we're gonna China her
and then we started trying any people
who we just don't like so like China's
coming out of the basket temporarily
she'll go back in she's coming out of
the basket because there's news about
her and it sounds very interesting when
they put her right here great happy to
see China how are you good how's your
boutique doing good yeah teak yeah she
sells liquid lip glosses and swatches
him on her arm just like Kylie it's so
pathetic are you good yeah let me dream
let me Kardashian hope fun doing
accessible let me give you the tea
because it's really crazy I haven't
heard this yet
Rob Kardashian recently filed court
documents with requests that would
reduce China's time with dream to only
weekends with a nanny serving as a
supervisor
according to reports this is that Kris
Jenner lawyer wait Rob's legal documents
also request China submit to drug and
alcohol testing no fewer than half an
hour prior to her visit with her
daughter the supervising nanny would
also have the authority to terminate
China's visits with dreams should he or
she witness any violence around the
three-year-old Rob also claims China has
been snorting cocaine and making violent
threats to people including strangers in
her home he also alleged she's gotten
physical by throwing objects at people
including her hairstylist she once
allegedly attacked with a knife all of
China's alleged behavior has purportedly
taken a toll on dream who Rob claims has
started acting out as a result dream has
started quote oh my god naked twerking
and acting out sexual positions that she
said her mom taught her claims Rob
according to documents in oh my Kenzie
this is so dream has she's twerking and
acting out sexual positions that she
said her mom taught her according to
according to court documents obtained by
TMZ I mean this is so horrible like we
can laugh in whatever like it's good
fodder for gossip but at the end of the
day like this is a child and I hate I
literally hate no and if this is true
like we've got to get her out of that
house
and I hate to play the blame game and
Rob's doing the right thing with that
Christian or fancy legal team but like
this is what happens when you have a
baby out of spite
right this is this is horrible and it's
so terrible to say and this may be this
might actually be the worst thing I've
ever said on this show but like it
almost would've been better if the kid
was never born like is that bad like
when it's like because Rob is going
through so much blac chyna is sworn in
cocaine and torquing it and attacking
her hairstylist so neither one of them
really want to be a parent oh well who
says that Rob doesn't mind she's very a
lot I guess I just assumed that because
he's never around yeah but you don't
know like what he's really up to I
actually just read an article that he is
gonna go away to a play time facility to
lose weight to lose weight um
so where's dream gonna go and also
that's mean I'll forget that Kendall did
say on James Corden that Rob is the best
parent of all the siblings so right I
mean she said that for a lot of reasons
okay I don't like truth being one of
them but she said though I'm not
doubting I take that back I don't think
he's a bad parent I just think like this
baby was almost like inconvenient for
them and they never like really change
their lives to include a baby which is
not in China yeah lakeil actively yeah
like they just they thought it would
like make them more money and become
more famous and then the rug got pulled
out from underneath them and Rob went
back like kind of into hiding in black
China wasn't famous anymore and she
couldn't change her name to Angelo
Kardashian and they like left the baby
behind and I think that the the girls
the Kardashians and the Jenners like
pick up a lot because they're they're
full-time mountains like that's all they
care about and they're all such good
moms they think they they take the kid
in the lot like they throw the kid
birthday parties and said yeah like
honestly temporarily I think that dream
should like live with the west's they
seem to have a really balance like
family life yeah or with Khloe or with
Kourtney or no but there's so many kids
at the West is probably so fun Jim will
forget about the fact that she just
learned how to twerk you know yeah this
is just terrible like so sad really
like when it's like it's like funny up
until it's like not and it's like this
is a child no it's not funny yeah no and
it's like it's really sickening and I
just can't believe they remember that
whole saga when he started dating black
chime and it was like so crazy and then
they were engaged and then they were
like doing you know pool parties in
Vegas doing appearances together and
then she got pregnant and like that's
when it stopped being funny yeah like it
was a joke
but until it wasn't
I just what is crazy twist for this
story to take yeah you know I just I
really hope the kids okay and honestly I
hope that this is just like a lie I just
didn't write like it's who can even come
up with crazy [ __ ] like this like the
kid simulating sex positions I can't I
can't
okay I'm gonna switch gears I got a
major way here because our fifth and
final story is a little bit of tech news
I guess it's tech and business because
CES took place this week you know it's
he is worse the Consumer Electronics
Show that we weren't invited to in Vegas
um we need to go next year we're a
consumer electronic brain we are we
really really are live show I just want
to go to Vegas
um and we're going to make it I'm so
excited but some new tech products
coming out of CES and I thought might
pique your interest are you ready yeah
the four days show which opened Tuesday
is a place for companies to unveil their
products and services for the coming
year though Apple Google and other tech
giants off often hold their older their
own announcement events streaming
services and surveillance technologies
are among the hot topics this year here
are some highlights from the show one
product that deals with nutritional DNA
a London startup believes it can help
you make healthier diet choices at the
grocery store using your own DNA DNA
nudge collects your DNA through a cheek
swab and sends data related to a
nutrition to a wristband if you have a
genetic predisposition to high blood
pressure the wristband will tell you to
stay away from salty snacks
so like the wristband will tell you how
to shop for groceries based on your DNA
for me that's a little too big brother
yeah also like you take my DNA all you
want but you just don't know my mood and
sometimes oh should we put it back in
the basket I think she goes back in good
sometimes my mood is like I'm not even
hungry I just want to eat like is my DNA
gonna be able to tell you that I'm just
bored
ya know but the DNA is just tryin to
keep you healthy yeah well you know what
everyone just like and their attempts to
keep me healthy it's not working okay so
just let me alone okay this next one is
the best idea I've ever heard it's
called it's not called anything oh it's
called partying no need to shaker stir
these machines will mix cocktails for
you
oh they're lighter jarred coffee
machines but for booze drop in a pod
filled with ingredients slide in the
glass and less than
later you'll have a martini or a Moscow
Mule in fact one of the gizmos is made
by Keurig drink works by Keurig sells
for $299 and can make Kosmos and fizzy
drinks such as vodka sodas each pod
makes one cocktail and cost about four
dollars
okay about the soda yeah but you put
your alcohol choice in like what would
be the water so container in the in the
pod is no alcohol no just the
ingredients the pod mixes in juices
herbs and other flavorings and then a
touch screen on the bar teas Ian lets
you choose how stiff you want your drink
there's even an option for alcohol-free
mocktails
cute I think this is really cute I be
sure there's a way for it to work with
your actual Keurig machine
cuz I don't want big to big hunks of
junk in my counter yeah no I mean it
does sound expensive so if you buy a box
of pods how much is it like $60 Oh for
all the dollars a pod 250 for a pod for
a bird not the Keurig version parties
ian is not carry a lot of cute named
Barty's Ian yeah I think this is a
really cute idea what she came out 5
years ago when I was really enjoying
cocktails at my home you know
yeah where you just whip up cocktails in
your house ever I used to remember when
he took a bartending class you won the
contest and I used to make drinks for
everyone during pregame oh yeah it was
so excited those cute I could have
really used this machine you could be on
Vanderpump rules
I could be our back a few other new tech
advances is Google's adding a privacy
undo feature to its assistant voice
technology so you know how your machines
are always listening to you well if you
say something in front of Google and you
want her to forget it you say hey Google
that wasn't for you and children very
cute
like that well it just get data in all
their Google homes you have to buy a new
one
hopefully it will just update yeah also
Samsung has an idea for a new robot
friend that's as simple as a ball that
rolls along beside you it's called your
Bali wall-e yeah very cute just like a
friend for Theo
also I just remembered remember how the
other day we said we need to get like a
music speaker in the studio I have an
extra Google home like Ben got at some
conference she bring in okay Google that
wasn't for you yes she gonna be
listening to us yeah it was a woman or a
man and I feel like she's a woman like
she's like sensitive yes me okay I'm
really excited to be kept in her from
pearls I do have a lot of controversial
thoughts that I do think will be
unpopular before I do that let me let
you guys know that this
internals recap is brought to you by
super cooter it's a new year the perfect
opportunity to take your business to the
next level
and that's exactly what we're doing here
at our new studio and you could take
your business to the next level by
hiring the right people the finding
qualified candidates it can be
challenging very very true
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter had a quality candidate
through the site within the first day so
our listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive address zip
recruiter dot-com / toast that zip CIP
recruiter re crui ter dot-com flash
toast toas team again that zip recruiter
comm / toast really premium for anyone
who wants to elevate their business and
honestly who doesn't sign-on elevate
your business Susan a premiere
Vanderpump rules the gang is back
together we have three new cast mates I
want to count really quickly how many
cast mates we now have I want to know
how many people will be at the Reunion
the three new ones yeah the six couples
so that's Tom Ariana Jax Brittney Katie
Tom
yes Aussie boho that's 11 Kristen 12
James 13 Raquel Raquel Lala
15 yeah that's that's it is that it yeah
but I feel like some people won't be at
the Reunion maybe the whole time Kristen
well it seems like the whole season's
about her I know and I'm so not
interested I can't even tell you okay
look there's the sir from the beginning
because we've been saying for a really
long time that this show needed to
evolve that we need a new blood you know
having these people who are married now
living in two million other houses
pretending that they're still waitresses
at Sur and is so silly it's so silly
lalala being on a private plane and
going to hos fixer is so silly and I'm
getting so drunk and destroying their
lives these lives that they're building
and they're important is so silly so I'm
really glad that were getting fresh
blood it's almost like they took our
feedback because they said Katy no
longer works at sur la la no longer
works at Sur like all the ones who are
really like set in their life like don't
need to be working at Sur
yeah just to pretend that there
it's so stupid like yeah so I'm really
glad that they did that I just didn't
like how it started with the new people
there are so many better ways to
integrate them into the storyline like
Sheena you know we could have seen every
want all the OGS and then like Sheena's
talking to this guy and this guy and
then they become part of the show and
you know Peters talking to Dana and I
just didn't bother me actually and I
actually thought um I always hate new
people and I think maybe the way to
introduce them was good because I
actually thought they all were kind of
interesting I like Dana a lot I really
like her conversation with Peter I think
I would have remembered making out with
a pirate it's just she's hilarious she's
hilarious she's really beautiful and I
like that she stands up for herself and
too and doesn't like take [ __ ] she
seems like very bla la SVA and the
conversation at the housewarming where
like max just like that's right like
that was so cute
yeah and she like wasn't being a freak
she was like wait but Arnie was you know
like right very normal straightforward
response right and now I guess like
Sheena is gonna be part of this next
generation and their drama yeah yeah and
honestly the fact that it that guy
called her boy crazy I actually thought
was like pretty a nice way to put it
soft yeah like I don't think that's a
terrible term no it's like we saw her on
the date with Robbie then she was dating
Adam and then I think really she was
with Rob yes it's a thing it's a perfect
manicure because there's so many other
meaner things you could say I think
boy-crazy is kind of like a sweet term
and then she's crying she's like I'm not
crazy it's like you're not doing a good
job of convincing us that no not at all
so I just wish the initial integration
of the new people was a little different
because at first I was just like what is
this show that I'm watching this is not
my show right but I guess their way of
integrating it was them being at Tom Tom
with Tom and Tom yeah so I like
everything is really moving in a natural
direction and they're figuring out ways
to integrate people even like Lala
working for Vanderpump dogs now and
obviously she doesn't need a hosting job
but she wants to the LAN thirteen she's
like a rich housewife she's gonna be on
Beverly Hill soon her being a full-time
philanthropist is perfect it's perfect
it all really worked if they're working
it out some of the people are not really
connected to leaves anymore but now it's
like Stassi and Lisa are just friends
yeah the only person who's not connected
to Lisa anymore is Stassi
because Tom and Tom and Ariana are
covered Jack still works at Sur so
Kristen is not because they've had bad
blood for years suck a dick Dianna yes
she's really out except for the fact
that her life seems to be the most
tumultuous right now therefore
interesting
I want to get that but right before I
just really want to touch on the fact
that I love that Stassi brought up the
fact that Tom Jax and the other Tom all
had the same house Oh totally because
I've been seeing them on Instagram and I
know that they're all like colonial
white new bills and they literally look
so similar and I love that someone
pointed it out because you couldn't pick
one out in the lineup
it's really true and they're all being
like competitive about their houses and
I know everyone when I was that watch
happens live like all the polls were
like Jax is being a dick but like I kind
of understood him like I didn't think he
was being a drama queen and you know
what he wants to me cuz one thing to be
about himself an he wants to be like a
groomzilla like that's his prerogative
we should deal with so much during Katie
and Tom's writing like why is he not
entitled to now be a little bit annoying
I just think I agree because of the
precedent that people have sent making
this summer about them if their birthday
falls during the summer it's my summer
yeah like are you are you kidding me but
for me like in my life I would not
tolerate anyone who uses their wedding
as an excuse for things outside of their
wedding weekend you know that's what
this group is like using things as their
excuse like yeah some people are going
through stuff like you can't be mean to
them because you're at Katie's set that
precedent yeah okay okay but they like
they made up but I got the vibe from
what trappings I've last night that
Katie I know Tom Sandoval and Jax aren't
still not on good terms I think it gets
worse yeah it's weird because and Jax
was obviously wrong that Tom never sent
him that text but it's like there are
probably unspoken things um between
people that it's like even if you send
that text it's like the subtext of it
you know I just didn't think like
everyone was so like strongly agreeing
with Tom Sandoval and I just wasn't like
either one of them were totally right or
wrong I just didn't take Tom's side so
strongly like everyone else and the
audience seemed to I just feel like
there's intangible weirdness and Jack
like and people them all acting like
being demoted from a best man to a
groomsman is a big deal like ridiculous
no I'm having more than one best man to
begin with and then Tom Schwartz being
like it's gonna be so much pressure
being the best man I felt like are you
guys [ __ ] kidding me
no I think the unspoken weirdness has a
lot to do with like the competitive
nature of just like now being
full-blown celebrities like how how big
is your house two million dollars one
point nine like I think that there's an
unspoken competitive nature to of being
on that show and being at the level of
success that they are because like they
all they have they all just do the same
thing and they have the same house
I live in the same neighborhood and they
do the same job and they work at Sur and
then they're making making money per
episode I think there's definitely like
a weirdness yeah comes like just being
competitive that's natural yeah it's
just like an awkwardness what's like we
all came from nothing now we all want to
be bigger and better than than each
other yeah and six tosses on her own
planet with her New York Times
best-selling book and her podcast and
her tour like it's it's definitely
competitive its competitive for I think
Tom Tom and Jax
agreed everyone else kind of has their
own thing going on yeah um I just want
to say like as the resident like an
apologist I have nothing to apologize
for today um I love her so much she
looked so beautiful I'm so happy that
she's sober um and the way she talks
about being sober it's like it just
makes it everyone want to be show better
so you want to be sober like I actually
when I was making my bed this morning
watching and I was like I wonder would
be so we're like it makes you just think
of it as a possibility no I like I just
like I'm not a full vegetarian like I
don't really drink as much as I used to
and I just could really relate to her
she wanting to change her life like that
I knew out like a new outlook on life as
like a mature person who doesn't need
alcohol to have fun yeah so I was really
proud of her she looked absolutely
stunning at Lisa's house I yes but my
unpopular opinion comes in now um when
it comes to Lala and all the girls as it
relates to Kristen um I just thought it
was like so unfair of them to just be
done with Kristen because her life is
messy messy and it's like are you
kidding me like good for all you guys
are all in great relationships you're
all moving into houses you're getting
married and that's amazing and and I
commend you but like don't discount the
fact that you were all in a very similar
place as Kristen not two years ago like
I just think it's so unfair of them to
just like now because they all have
their life together and Kristen is like
kind of taking her time getting there
for them to just totally discount and
like think she's being annoying and I
just is she being done with Carter like
1,000% but like be dumb and why do they
care and honestly Kristen me the
greatest point christma like if I ever
went up to Randall and started having a
conversation about her relationship with
with Lala if they were in a fire or
something like that would be so
inappropriate and I get that Carter it's
like just like a hanger on ER but it's
like that's Kristen's problem and like
she's working through it and it's maybe
not the way that you want her to work
through it but just like be a friend and
you could be annoyed I have friends who
make bad decisions and
like you just talking but that's what
being friend is like you don't have to
agree with what everyone is doing I just
thought it was so unfair of them
it's like cast stones on Kristen just
because her life is kind of messy when
it's like now okay now you know sows is
a best-selling author Lala's marrying a
millionaire like okay their lives all
got together and good for them but like
just not not fair to just totally right
Kristen off because she's being annoying
because her life isn't right like I just
thought that was so unfair I agree with
you I could see how you see it that way
but I do think when you get older and
your time is more precious because you
have more responsibilities and and when
you're getting married and it's just a
whole nother chapter of your life like
the time that you have for your friends
dwindles it's not like it wasn't your
20s when you're living next door to each
other and you can just like pal around
all day and to spend your time with
someone who makes bad decisions and
doesn't take accountability for them and
then backtracks and lies it's like no
one has time for that and I understand
why it's like if I had a friend who was
just I couldn't get behind anything that
they were doing any advice I gave them
fell on deaf ears and they just continue
to be on this hamster wheel yeah I would
be like you know what this is not a good
use of my time you do what you want to
do like I'm out but that's not really
what they're saying they're like yelling
at her for the decisions that she's
making and I just think like and maybe
that's just the type of friend I am like
if someone's being not taking my advice
making poor decisions right like that's
on you I'm not going to stop being your
friend I just think you're done No
you'll just think that anything that's
what they're saying it's like okay I
know what it looks like do whatever
because it's a waste of time to give
someone advice and like try and help
them through something when they just
won't help themselves so like I agree
with you it's like take my advice do
whatever you want but when I'll just
think that you're dumb so that's not a
friendship anymore when it's like I
can't even talk to you know for sure but
it's like and Kristen is is wrong in the
sense that like she's making poor
decisions but it's like she's obviously
not in a good place it's almost like
kicking someone when they're down you
think it's easier easy for her to like
see everyone like getting married
getting engaged like it sucks and like
that's all she wants and she's like
can't get out of this bad place that
she's in and I just think everyone like
blaming her for like being a mess but it
sounds Invader seem like she even tries
because he for them like it's just like
the baseline of her trying you think it
was easy when Stassi broke up with
Patrick and she had nowhere to live and
she had to go find her own apartment
like Kristen can't even kick Carter out
Carter doesn't even bring anything to
the table like if she didn't know if she
decided she wanted to make a change in
her life like she would have Carter
leave like and her friends would be
there for her she would be so [ __ ]
sad but her friends would be there for
her you don't get to be sad and also be
broken up and be together and have your
friends there for you because it's just
a waste of time I know and as a person
who is very rational like you I get that
but I just think it's like she's
obviously going through a lot it's not
made any better by the eventual if she
refuses to go through our thriving it's
so she's not going through it she's
obviously very attached to Carter and
she's handling it in a way that I would
never handle it and one that I don't
agree with but I just think for your
friends to like think you're so annoying
just because they're at a different
place in their life is like so unfair
like she's like kind of the underdog
like just be nice and I just think like
everyone's life has been so messy
friendship is being honest with people
we've seen it all play out over the
years like everyone's idiocy like with
their boyfriends and kristen has been
there for every single one of them and I
just think like now they're all like
living and I've been there for her and
they've been here for her when she was
acting in an age-appropriate manner but
now like they're well into their 30s
like if you break up with someone he has
to move out of your apartment I thought
for a second she was gonna say he was
moving into the new house with her which
seems like that was a plan until he
moved to aim with his friend right yeah
I just think everyone's being really
really hard on her and she's like I
didn't think Lala was being hard on
arted and then I think when when I
thought Lala was being very gentle and
Kristen called her a [ __ ] like no no
yeah Kristen called Lala [ __ ] like
that's exactly what she was being she
was being so mean and so [ __ ] and like
so just like on this moral high ground
when it's like it's just it's it's just
unfair like I can't explain it in any
other way it's like they've all been
through so much [ __ ] and they all are
lucky enough that like they came out on
the other side and Kristen isn't it
lucky she's been through it with them to
like just drink they don't have to put
in the hard work to come out on the
other side and she's working on it
that's all I'll say like I think she's
working on it but we've only been seeing
they're actually like this has been
going on for so long we went through so
much [ __ ] with like Katie and Tom
and all of stassi's boyfriends for years
and we've only really been hearing about
this carter stuff since last season but
what about Kristen and Tom we've been
hearing him out like oh yeah but that's
a totally different relationship yeah
but like she's they've been like she's
been there for them but they've been
there for her but you get to a point in
life where you have to become mature and
I understand saucy saying like I'm
growing into the person I want to be and
to be friends with someone who's not
growing at all and growth growth means
like doing hard things that you don't
want to do including telling your
ex-boyfriend to leave your apartment and
he if he's not your boyfriend to end the
relationship like her
comparing Stassi breaking up with
Patrick and being like I can never do
that so you're basically saying I could
never break up with someone right no she
say she's definitely [ __ ] and she's
handling this so poorly
I just don't think and she's actually
making it more difficult for herself
[ __ ] I just don't think that her
friends like being so hard on her and
like me to her is gonna help her at all
but I don't think anything can help her
honestly except for self yeah except
herself so I understand that they're
people who deal in tough love I'm one of
those people to you it just seems a
little hypocritical for everyone to like
suddenly just like distance himself
somewhere because she's going through it
when it's like they're now just being
like are we went through it like a few
years ago like now we're over it like
everyone had has had [ __ ] on the show
everyone has been through a lot I have
to publicly like break up and yet she's
handling it poorly I just think it's
like solely for critical of them like no
oh we're we're all good now we're
married in our big houses like [ __ ]
Kristen I did I don't think it's like
that because if she were really going
through because she's not going through
it she complains about the breaking up
and then she's not broken up so if she
were going through it and at her low
point and single like they would be
there for her but she refuses to even
get to that point and she just like
wants to live in this like purgatory you
know and they can't stay there with her
I just think it's a little hypocrite I
understand but I think a you and your
patience level if you had a friend like
that you would have absolute I think
it's easy for you to ask them to be
better friends when it's not your time
that's being given um no because I I can
compare it to relationships in my life
where it's like people are on the
downward spiral and they're making bad
decisions and I still talk to them and
help them through it and it's annoying
they never take my advice but that's
just what being a friend is like it
doesn't take a lot of effort to give
advice like and if the person wants to
follow it or not great you did your job
as a friend like not that serious i but
for the amount that they all hang out i
don't think that you can relate to
having a friend like that who like
really drained yeah you can pick up the
phone and say whatever you want but then
you go back to your life but like these
people are so intertwined in their own
lives that when like kristin is bringing
everyone down like they really feel it's
not just like a 20-minute phone call
that's uncomfortable and then move on do
you know what I mean yeah I don't know I
just think it's like a family member I
think that right
and you're therefore family no matter
what even if they're being dumb and
annoying no but at a certain point it's
like figure it out for yourself like I
can't help you anymore for sure but
they're being mean in the process like
the way that there's like I think the
waist and then like I think the way Lalo
I was speaking to Christine is so
condescending it's like good for you
while like your life is all together
because you met a man who change your
life but like that's not happening for
everyone and I just think that like the
condescension is so hypocritical because
they've all been through [ __ ] and
they're all lucky enough to have come
out on the other side any of them could
have been Kristen yeah but that's the
point it's like will you make the
changes to not be that but Kristen won't
make those changes I don't think she's
as mentally strong as everyone else then
get strong [ __ ] it's so much easier
said than done
you as someone who is mentally strong do
you know anything in there's just
something about her that's like a little
sad and I think everyone to be doing a
better job at like at least just like
coddling her and I know that that
nothing has been for how long forever
until she figures out it's her life at
some point it's like it's your life do
what you want to do but like I'll be
your friend I just I think their
definition of friendship is so much more
labor-intensive than yours
for sure but are you comparing it to
family yeah yeah no not family because
family you can't ever cut off you know
so I think that's the type of like
friendship they all have yeah I agreed
you know yeah but I don't know maybe
like a cousin yeah no I get tough love
it's just so much easier said than done
you know mm-hmm and honestly I've never
really liked bend or tough breakups I
don't know how easy this just cut
someone off and maybe like Kristen's
right like Stassi is very like she
compartmentalize it's like she cut
Patrick Robin it was probably really
hard for a but like she just did it some
people just aren't that strong and then
I think Kristen is one of those people
I'm sure it's really annoying to be your
friend but like be a friend like I think
it's especially annoying when you've
been through it
it's like Stassi handling it like
Brittany's not totally cutting off
Kristen even though I know she probably
thinks persons making bad decisions but
Brittany like has a heart of gold and
she's just one of those people and not
and most of us aren't that know I think
the other the other girls are way too
extreme on the other side look I think
they're just being human about it like
it's [ __ ] annoying their busy day of
lives and and it's just like we can't
keep doing this make a decision and
stick to it even if you even if that
means staying with him they would
support that too just stop going back
and forth
I just think it's like really extreme
like you don't agree with someone else's
decision-making so you're gonna cut them
off like you're not I don't think anyone
ever said cut off but like they're like
I'm done out like it's just it's so
final and it's like at the end of the
day they didn't do anything to hurt you
they're just making a knowing decision I
wasn't getting cut off vibes but it's
like I no longer care about this do what
you want but then if you don't care
about someone's life like that's not a
friendship
Katie passed I wrote in the comments
this conversation is very cancer Scorpio
like I think I'm being a real cancer
right now like sensitive weenie I think
you're being really scorp we all like
really cutthroat yeah I guess I guess
that I am but I think it's also hard for
us to relate right I've never because
we're not people in their 30s dealing
with fellow 30 year olds who are just
not growing in the right and I and I
don't know how I would act I totally got
what stassi's hanging it's definitely
frustrating to like be evolving in your
life and everyone around it was bobbing
except one person it's like kind of
dragging you down like that doesn't
warrant cutting off a friendship like
just because you don't agree with
someone's life choices doesn't mean that
they can't be your friend people are
different but it's a different it's not
cutting off a friendship like it just
becomes a different kind of friendship
which is what they're saying like
Kristen yeah you'll be my friend
whatever but it's not gonna be like how
it was it's because I can't spend that
much time I feel like it was very final
like they wanted nothing to do with her
anymore just because she's like a little
sad yeah oh my god there is a crazy
person in the YouTube stream it make no
yeah get her out of here the drama oh
you're all over it okay um it seems like
it's gonna be really good to season oh
they premiered a clip for the wedding
and I saw myself in the audience just
like I think I was smoking a jewel which
is so disgusting
that's so funny yeah it looks like a
good season um I'm excited
it'll be really interesting like I feel
like this is a very big moment to see
how the show is gonna move forward you
know is it gonna become very is it gonna
become Vanderpump rules
jet NexGen or is it gonna become a show
a show about adults and I'll go with
happily that I'm here for the show Bab
adults because I love this crew that
we've come to LA and they're still
adults but they're very silly with like
the water gun beer like it's funny right
um so it'll be interesting to see how
this show unfolds yeah I'm excited
anything else yes to key-in or anything
yes we saw CSI a little while ago I'm so
glad that everyone could watch it the
show is so good it's so beautiful Kara's
back did she had her nose done yes yes
it looks the same uh her gallery or so
weird her and Kelsey like can't [ __ ]
stand each other and I don't really I
get like that they're supposed be hating
each other over gallery but it seems
like a little bit more extreme I think
they both saw what each other said about
each other on the last season and that
kind of went below the belt and they
like are coming out
coming in hot yeah but obviously the
most important for the episode was the
fact that Madison came back from LA this
is the part that we could not get over
that we were teasing that we were just
like you guys have to see this to
believe this Madison came back from my
leg telling everyone she has a new
boyfriend who's older and he happened to
have been the producer of their show for
the first two seasons what's his name I
don't know I remember or something um
not only is he like so much older he's
just like not what you would expect like
over like Madison no not only so much
older like if she had another man cool
but like a former producer on their show
like I'm shipped to the [ __ ]
core like he was there producing her
while she was like dating Brenda and I
now he's on the show like taking shots
when he was literally behind the camera
not three months it's so crazy and be
like dating a teacher yeah Mary Kay
Letourneau and teachers come in a house
party it's so weird it's just it's
honestly disgusting made even more
disgusted the fact that honestly he's
not cute like it's just the weirdest
thing ever and honestly Chloe's reaction
but like Madison seems to be the one
with that her head screwed on the
straightest out of everyone she's such
like a good smart girl so like if this
if she's so happy and so in love like I
before it and I believe in it especially
because everyone on the show was like so
immature and they're not ready for real
relationships and it seems like she is
so I'm happy for her know that I am and
I believe in it because I believe in her
you know yeah I just think that she's
really never been like my favorite
character but now she's one of the most
interesting characters like this is so
odd I'm very curious to see how it plays
out he meets her dad and the dad is like
this is weird he's too old for you now
he's just like drinking with them and
that's the weirdest part cuz he used to
be their boss his name is ish ish ish
which is I just the whole thing is so
weird
Juliet is back she's not dating Alex
anymore um she's with Robbie who now you
know Chloe and Amanda are like is he
right for you like what its intentions
um they're not together right now so I
just think like watching them will be a
waste of my time no one also like Julia
Porter is 21 years old like on a reality
show um just having the time of her life
like I don't care if Abby he's is right
for her like it's not about that no
she's living we're not gonna be seeing
them down the aisle she
a bit fun and she is fabulous bit and
fun yeah and she's whatever she like
she's not making choices that are gonna
affect her in the long term it's like I
feel like it's like meeting the parents
right what are your intentions well I'm
glad she finally graduated college I
think that'll really change like this
scheduling yeah she oh I think she'll be
around when we're not to watch her like
driving back and forth to have
Tallahassee I think this is just really
good and I'm glad that she didn't drop
out of college like I think she easily
could Evans a girl who just like shot to
fame on a reality show like she thinks
people think their life is gonna change
meanwhile this key like could get
canceled and my cord like would go back
to being normal right um so I'm glad
that she graduated college I think that
was like a really responsible thing for
her to do and I'm sure it was really
annoying the last year but I don't think
also like having classes and homework
and tests like gave her life a lot of
structure and I think now without that
like it's just gonna be a free-for-all
so her and Kelsey are like jet-setting
around the world we haven't wasted and
Whistler yes there Cooper like it's it's
a mess but it's great it looks really
fun yeah I'm gonna be good season I
think they pretty much confirmed that
Alex's girlfriend is pregnant we saw on
Instagram they had a gender reveal that
they're having a girl so I'll be very
interested to see how all that came
about and how Juliet just unravel it's
so [ __ ] shocking this seems to be like
a great season so we'll keep recapping
it yeah snatcher will be recapping it
you have a new episode of the snatchler
new episode of mood and data a new
episode of date night there's just so
much content will have a new patreon
episode for you soon so I hope that you
know we can help get you through these
long days it's oh it's lunch time you
guys it's 11:40 head over to Sally grab
the water cooler and go get lunch thank
you so much for listening to the morning
testimony a morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube we're also
available as podcasts anywhere podcasts
can be found so it's about if I iTunes
stitcher I Heart Radio Public Radio
cashbox there's so many places so
whether you watch on YouTube or on your
podcast app but please leave a
subscription leave a review about five
stars Matt a stunning beautiful and
smart we are would love you guys so much
we will see you tomorrow have a good one